et puis une activité un peu plus douce
que le football proposé à des personnes
âgées et dépendantes n allez voir c'est
formidable s'appelle de la danse
aérienne ou de la danse voltige les
animatrices de l'épade intercommunale de
la mambrle Semblancay ont décidé de
remuer ciel et terre pour permettre aux
résidents de sortir de leur zone de
confort au programme des acrobaties dans
les airs alors en douceur des
chorigraphies et une représentation qui
se prépare elles emmènent tous les
mardis après-midi un groupe de
volontaires au gymnase de neuiller
pompière un moment suspendu auquel a
assisté romain
Delville allez on lève le
[Musique]
brantverrouille les
articulations échauffement en douceur
avant de faire les acrobates pour ces
résidents des épades de semblanc et de
la mambrle le temps de se mettre en
place on s'assoit pas
maintenant et c'est parti pour la danse
voltige
[Musique]
sentiment d'aesanteur légèreté pour
jeune viève la doyenne du groupe c'est
un vrai plaisir je je suis bien ouais
très bien même j'ai pas peur non j'ai
pas peur du toutère qu' cru c'est vrai
mais j'ai peur de rien j'y vais
carrément je me dis vas-y vas-y c'est
tout se balancer entre ciel et terre est
moins évident pour Philippe qui a du mal
à lâcher prise un peu de de crainte par
que dès que dès que j'ai pu les pieds
sur terre je je me sens un peu
déséquilibré donc un peu de crainte en
tout une quinzaine de résidents ont
suivi les 12 séances de danse aérienne
de Syvie six accompagné par Mélanie et
Isabelle animatrice en épade et Laurence
duciad pour cette première initiation
avec des personnes âgées ou dépendantes
la la prof de danse a elle-même fait
sauter ses a
prioris super félicitations et en fait
c'est eux qui nous apporte énormément
parce que nous on est là on se bloque on
se dit par rapport à leur âge mais eux
en fait ils foncent ils sont demandeurs
et on sent bien qu'ils sont hyper
heureux de venir ils arrivent ils ont
toujours la banane donc ben voilà c'est
eux qui nous pent c'est qu'au fil des
séances l'appréhension s'est dissipée et
les plus habiles les plus mobiles se
sont laissés aller à des figures au
début c'était un peu difficile on voyait
des gens qui étaient extrêmement tendus
très raides et qui au fur et à mesure
parce qu'on venait une fois par semaine
donc au fur et à mesure ils se sont
détendus ils ont eu confiance dans le
matériel et aussi ben avec nous pour
clôturer le projet danse aérienne dans
les épades les résidents proposeront en
janvier une
représentation histoire de montrer leurs
progrès histoire aussi de prouver à leur
famille qu'ils s'épanouissent dans les
airs